well let's hear what labor is expecting
from the budget uh Pat McFadden Shadow
Chief Secretary of the Treasury joins me
now and first of all you must be pleased
about the energy price cap guarantee
being extended that's going to make
quite a difference to people isn't it
well this is one of a number of things
that we've called for which if the
pre-budget speculation and leaks and
briefing are to believe that the
government's going to do and there's a
bit of a pattern here where we call for
things like extending the energy price
guarantee or or keeping fuel Duty where
it is and we're accused of being
incredibly fiscally profligate and the
rivers will run red and labor is going
to bankrupt the country and so on and a
few weeks later uh the government adopts
what we're saying but uh I don't mind if
we lead the way as long as they do the
right thing and I think it's important
to do that because the cost of living
crisis has not gone away people are
really struggling to pay their bills and
as things stood those bills were
scheduled to go up another 500 pounds a
year in a couple of weeks time so I
think it's right to extend that
guarantee so if anything your policies
and they've stolen your policy on child
care it's difficult for you to criticize
that isn't it well we welcome what uh
you know Child Care being put uh as a
big part of the budget we've also been
talking about this a lot in recent
months and the reason we've been doing
that is the costs are so expensive for
parents that it's become it's become a
Workforce issue it's become a real
economic issue because every business
that we speak to every and also public
sector employers talk about shortage of
staff and any of your viewers who've had
young children in recent years will know
just how expensive this system is so
we're going to look at the detail of
what's announced today but certainly
labor has been saying for some time that
we need to help parents with child care
if we're serious about addressing the
workforce issues in the economy and
that's what we want to see from any
child care announcement what will the
government's announcement is expected to
cost 4 billion pounds it's a it's a big
sum of money if you win the next
election you're going to have to make it
work aren't you how how is that compared
to the cost of your scheme it's and
we're always very careful with the the
cost of schemes because we're always
asked how are you going to pay for it
and quite rightly when we announce the
policy so for example uh on our child
care proposal we said we would fund it
of abolishing the non-dom status uh
where you know as a wealthy a tax break
for wealthier people where they can
choose the jurisdiction in which they
pay their tax and we said we would fund
our proposal of that there's been quite
a lot of spending announced by the
government uh in recent days we've had 5
billion for defense potentially 4
billion for this other announcements
today I don't mind being asked how will
you fund things but I hope it's a
question for conservative ministers and
not just labor spokespeople too we need
to fix the economy that's pretty clear
isn't it if this budget helps the UK
economy improve it's going to mean that
labor stand a harder chance of winning
at the next election isn't it what would
you rather a fixed economy or a labor
government well I want to live
I don't think that's the choice but this
is the big question is economic growth
uh whatever the individual measures in
this budget the backdrop is we are the
only G7 country not to recover a
pre-covered position and the IMF has
forecast forecast forecast us to have
among the weakest growth of major
industrial countries over the next two
years as long as that's the pattern
incomes will stagnate and it contributes
to the industrial action that we're
seeing today there's upward pressure on
taxes and there's also pressure in our
Public Services because we're just not
generating enough wealth
and although there may be individual
measures which we've called for uh that
will be announced today I think the
government's failure on long-term growth
is the really big indictment of their 13
years in power
another element that we are expecting to
be announced today is possibly an
increase in public sector pay of course
we've got all of these these strikes
today
um potentially we think the government
may suggest that public sector pay rise
of up to 5.5 percent do you think we can
afford that as a country well I think uh
it's important that people are getting a
decent pay rise when inflation's been
running at 10 uh it's for the government
to negotiate this precise figure
um
uh well we'd have to be around the table
negotiating uh with her I mean we've
been reluctant I think quite responsibly
to get drawn on a specific percentage
because these things are always a
negotiation and what saddens me about
the industrial disputes is there's maybe
been too much rhetoric and here we have
the government legislating uh with our
threat to SAC nurses when we should be
hiring them they've got to get around
the table and resolve these disputes
because yet again today in a number of
sectors of the economy we've got major
industrial action with no end in sight
but isn't it a bit woolly to say you
know the government isn't isn't doing
the right thing here but but not to put
a figure on what what you think is the
right thing to do you're not a party to
the negotiations if we were in
government we would be and I couldn't
negotiations are very public aren't they
we never thought the nurses want we know
what the teachers want we never had
these kind of strikes when labor was in
power because we generated the economic
growth to make sure that the Public
Services were funded properly and the
people who worked in them were properly
rewarded that's the approach to we'll
take if we get into government right now
the government's got to negotiate a
settlement to these disputes which gets
people back to work and stops the
inconvenience to the public away from
the individual disputes but a more
broader across the broad public sector
pay Rises what level do you think would
be a sensible level that wouldn't fuel
inflation
of a percentage pay rise actually that's
got to be negotiated look the bigger
backdrop to this the pressure on but
that's not down to the workers that's
not that's not a figure that the
government is going to is gonna talk to
the workers about this is the thing that
the government's going to have in their
head we can't go above a certain point
because if they have it in their head
they haven't they haven't uh said what
that is but the bigger problem it comes
back to economic growth why have
people's income stagnate stagnated why
are they really feeling the pinch it's
because we haven't had enough economic
growth in the past 13 years and although
we've had a lot of budget leaks about
individual measures what we haven't had
is any sense that the chancellor and the
Prime Minister are content to do
anything other than manage decline the
problem for the conservatives know is
they've been in power for 13 years
there's no one left to blame when we
look at the economic growth record and
it's that growth record that has left
incomes under pressure
taxes on an upward trajectory and yet
our public services are still creaking
the only way out of that is better
economic growth and that's what we're
really looking for in the budget today
um there may be some things in the
budget that you would support I mean
we've already talked about child care
and and support for energy bills maybe
fuel Duty um help as well will you stand
with the government on on policies in
terms of of this budget if you think
they are good for the population yeah we
will because uh you know very often the
government says Labor's not fit to run
the country they're Reckless they're
irresponsible yet time after time they
are adopting things that we've suggested
we've already discussed the energy price
freeze we suggested freezing fuel Duty
we put Child Care at the center of the
political agenda we also said there
needed to be more action to for
investment allowances to get businesses
to invest more we've really been setting
the agenda for these things it does seem
that the government really doesn't have
many years of its own
we shall see Pat mcfan Shadows Chief
secretary thank you very much